so this is golf around not golf with
your friends the golf around
click and push for okay who's oh my god
is it do we have turns is it me do we go
at the same time
okay all right oh oh we just go
that's right we just all go
e that was too much i made it i'm
getting horrible flashback
yeah this is um it's gonna be fine also
jumping is totally on yeah i don't know
uh collision is on so please get the
hell out of my goddamn way
how about you get out of my way welp oh
you weighing get real good there
yes
yeah there's balls yard balls could
touch
the jump oh yeah the jump the jump you
all took two strokes it looked like you
took like three no no
i'm not this is not gonna work oh it
worked
oh i love that that's so
nice look out
i did it what an adorable game of just
regular old mini golf this is actually
nice
oh who hit me who
hit me someone hit me
oh i think i hit you yeah you did why
sorry
sorry sorry there we go oh that jump
actually
suck all right it's okay oh no wade's in
the lead by one who put
two no jesus i think it's meant to
distract me guys
all right okay oh no not the bread
guys the bread really kept me out of the
hole there i feel cheated
this is delightful it's so nice
esports mini golf look man you're about
to see some maneuvers the likes of which
you've never seen
this music while delightful
is gonna make me kill myself not that i
don't like it i just hate it with every
fiber of my being
you don't like mobart you know like uh
guys why did that just make you do your
arm destroyed laughs
okay how do i turn this stupid music off
whatever you do don't like exit for
god's sake
because it just closes the game with no
warning or
as confirmation or anything arbitrary
how would you
wait what are your things going to shoot
out oh i see what happens
it's a game dude it's a game shoot
for your holding
good luck buddy i've gotta make it oh
yes
i did it i did it i did it
don't jump out don't do nothing it drops
you oh it drops you
hole into it seems fair
well that doesn't seem fair at all i
don't know what you want to do
first try oh that's not going in oh hell
yeah
oh come on three seven we're all
at the same seven we're all good here
wait what is what are we looking at what
oh
okay it's not the last one is it the
first one
i got the middle one which seems to be
okay
hey
bounce oh
god there goes my lead why did you yell
jump
i was trying to get scared
yes well i was tired of being in last
place after my seven
oh there's a weird it's a middle there's
a gate i got straps
oh i don't know about that one man okay
just because i was placed in the wrong
spot no i did it i did it
all right i'll take it off par
great job everybody look at this equal
anyway
i was wondering when you guys come back
i'm making it oh my god no
not this way no no no oh no
well i was just playing with fire wasn't
i oh my god oh oh
shoot i've got the stratagems
oh baby no no no no no no
oh
get out of here bob could you give me a
little push no hey hey hey hey bob come
on oh yes
i made a bar baby i just need a little
boop
oh
yeah i'm not giving you
all right okay what are you gonna do
come on hit me hit me i dare you get the
hell out of my way hit me i dare you
i will do anything in my power too okay
all right let's see
i will literally throw away everything
to avoid hitting you
thanks man my turn what
i'm waiting here they're gonna they're
gonna get they're gonna come get me
who's gonna get you they're gonna come
get me
you guys are gonna come get me we you
guys pick me up at the grocery store me
and bob we're gonna come get you why are
we gonna come get me you're
gonna hit me i'll come get you wade why
did this happen i just need one of you
to come
hey get out of my way what are you doing
what is this what yeah what is that
wait do we have to do we get in that
somehow so do we just have a solution to
this problem
wait go for it all right there you go
that'll get us
decided to keep going wow you guys suck
you suck but not you're good but i think
i'm definitely the best of us
yeah you are you are
oh no this was a mistake no my lead
i did the strats yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ]
didn't work i see ah good strats man
get away everybody get away from me get
away from me go in the hole
i will what is this oh no where is it
oh god i'm just
i'm scary i'm just gonna go this way i'm
gonna oh no too much speed too much feet
no
no don't do it go down the ramp it's
fine yeah i go
through go to the ramp it's fine water
no
why is this real where
how the hole where am i that's not the
hole is that the whole it has to be
right i'll go first if you're too
chicken i'm in the whole idiots how are
you oh
come on i'm better than you how did you
get down here
i went from the platform directly to the
hole because i'm
smarter just i'm turning off jumping
yeah wow i'm so smart and good at things
all right we're going to the dungeon
super also removes ball reticle
uh okay let's do extreme mode okay oh am
i out of the lobby wait did i just yes
you are
okay hang on let me just get back in
there oh you get the little
tip you just don't get the bottom left
thing that's cool i'm okay with that
that's cool yeah i'm into that oh here
we go oh my god
oh my god oh my god good bounce good
mouse good bounce baby these are sick
bounces pro bounces pro bounces problems
oh yeah good balance wait wait wait
keep going keep going god damn it daddy
doesn't ever call me anymore
oh yout she's a beaut
she's a beaut she's a beard
yeah good job look at me i'm so good
that you all are not as good as me
well you don't know that yet you don't
know that for certain i know that to be
true
you're gonna try to jump this one i bet
you can jump it bob i bet you can jump i
have a strat you got you want to see my
ultimate oh no worries
always do i always job
oh my god i think i got murdered what
happened oh that was too weak
oh i'm oh no no no
hey look i'm gonna make it come on over
buddy i'm gonna make it the water's
oh do you want me to push you in no get
away from me you only give you a little
no i don't oh [ __ ]
oh monk wait where's the hole
and you'll never guess which one it oh
biscuits mark was like you'll never find
the right oh and you knocked me right
wish me luck
oh look at martin oh
all right
oh no obviously oh no oh no okay
i'm fine i got an achievement from lava
oh there's achievement that sounds
pretty cool all right hey
uh hit me up oh
yep i'm going for it no
a little more powerful i don't want to
say that i'm an expert at this game
pretty sure that's
too far to jump it's not the ball okay
oh come on now there we go okay
let's jump oh yes oh books
books why am i stupid what did you do
i jumped over the whole jump off the
level oh god damn it
oh you jumped back over the wall yeah i
sure did
oh well you didn't die so that's
something yeah that's true
great job buddy
oh i was so close no come back oh no
please it's not in between the table
buddy keep going mark oh
what a show thanks man yeah thank you oh
man i thought you were gonna get it yeah
no not quite
but par hey i'll take part oh jesus
oh i was a little late ah watch this
yeah
oh there's a whole gap yo
hey mark how's it going hey what's up
dude can you get me in no
i can't do you just tell me god i went
the wrong way
is that all the way over there that's
really unpleasant all right well i'm not
in position to do a crazy jump so i'm
not going to try
i'm going for it i'm down i've never
been lower
hold it oh no yes
i think you should have definitely
jumped oh
me oh nice hop yeah i know thank you
oh look out physically no
i'm never gonna i'm never gonna make it
i made it okay
i made it okay just keep going
uh yes please a little more a little
more a little more yes
i mean he was watching me you guys want
to see the strategy for this one
i'm sure
yeah actually i do i do
please oh oh you got roasted
dude my my guys look my guys
hey thanks for letting me catch up mark
i appreciate that you're welcome oh
my god oh jumble wait what the hell oh
look i don't know man
you're too funny my my back hurts
laughing
thank you
there we go there you go
i feel like you were behind me by about
as much as you had previously been in
front of me thank you i don't know what
happened
thank you thank you man thank you ow
oh my god no oh help me
mark we gotta go
oh my gosh
gotta go oh go in i don't even care
oh my god
no not again aim somewhere else i don't
want to talk about it i don't want to
talk about it i don't want to talk about
it
mark you know what god damn it you tried
i didn't tell anyone you can ask
well oh i got roasted somehow damn it
okay
thank god a relatively normal one how
did you stop
incline bob you're a wizard i don't know
magically physics was just like
eh oh my [ __ ] sides
you guys damn i'm so happy i wow that is
the strat isn't it
i did it
oh god dang it i'm coming back baby
what is that it's fire well that's not
it
oh yes yes yes go go i'm setting up my
shot
so then wait wait wait wait wait it's
gonna be hot oh okay
it's real hot oh my god
oh god damn it yes yes yes yes i made
it yes this is the one what is this this
is the way
oh my god yeah [ __ ]
this is where i come back yes die die
die die die okay
okay it's fine there you go
that's a good thank god
did i win everyone equally good i can't
you won that
i can get second place yeah you can
catch me
after you buff
whoops
where old you guys didn't sound nearly
as excited as i did i may have goofed
oh the snake he swallowed i'm getting
dizzy
what oh my god there is oh my god
[ __ ] thrones
oh my god wait what happens if we get
roasted before we stop
moving
hey mark how are you doing i'm trying to
get out your way man that is
i'm in the hole baby i'm an idiot baby
oh god that was close it comes back
hey
just smacked us down i told you he was
kicking our ass the whole time
that would have been if i didn't [ __ ] up
on 17 so much oh
my body physically hurts from the amount
of joy that i'm getting oh
great i'm so happy
oh [ __ ] oh what i didn't even think
about the implications that that had on
that word
do i have to beep simple every time i
say probably yeah yeah
i think so okay nevermind oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh why
he why he why he why
here that's a cool corner mark why here
oh
oh oh well how did you do that oh well
i'm good
yeah did they put that sign there to
block us from jumping it's just
like bonk bonk boys
when you say that tell me what that is
so i don't know
oh my god oh my god oh my god please oh
that's fine nice jump idiot oh you're
mean whoa that's the point i was trying
to be
mean idiot go for it yeah
yes no do you die to snowballs no they
just really ruin everything don't they
oh my god i hate
life i'm going for it [ __ ] yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes
okay we're fine [ __ ] that's interesting
that's really interesting look where i
am is this good no
no it's not oh man that's really just
i'm a little i'm a wrinkled brain that's
what i
am i've never heard that as a it was a
brag before but man
it really does send a message it works
right why me
why me look we both made the same
mistakes okay
oh hey mark a little off to the right
you might want to be on the left you're
off to the right i
shouldn't have oh buddy
you want to see some wrinkly brain
nonsense always
ah [ __ ] that's not it where are you
going man where you going
is it the penguins is it the penguins oh
[ __ ] they're penguins here oh they
oh they kick they kick they kick they
like
they do not wear a glove you guys are
cheating with all your weird strats i am
oh a god i'm a god i'm a god why are you
against me
don't look at me i'm a god oh if you
would have messed me up i would
i wish i would have messed you up i know
it how balls go what do you mean mark i
meant as a compliment yeah but which
loop my brain's so wrinkled
wow what a wrinkle hey get away
i tried to help you you did not god it's
like the grand canyon in my brain man
and wow that's full of water no i wrote
it over
no well kind of bread
well it's kind of a pinkish gray full of
random famine colored
because of too many bone broth
you grilled too hard and now you got
bone broth madness
i'm pretty sure that's what they're
gonna call the disease that you get when
you drink too much bone broth i'm fairly
certain that it's called bone broth
magnesium
all right you guys want to see the
strats do you guys want to see the
strats yeah i actually
got ah where did you go oh god
wait oh oh [ __ ] that was god perfect
and i have the wrinkliest brain of us
all goddamn how am i gonna
how am i gonna uh [ __ ] i gotta do it
brain is all smooth
like a dude it is like a sea cucumber
no okay well that was just not great
mark
was reaching for the stars
stop believing
stop believing stop i gotta tell you
dorothy stop believing
well it would be great if i wasn't
positioned in between them
role was that hey dude
wow you're successful i gotta be honest
that looks like
sadness i'm gonna drive to san francisco
and i'm i have a real shot at this i'm
gonna i'm gonna
are you threatening me sir i'm gonna
drive to san francisco and i'm gonna
shake your hand mister that is the most
terrifying thing i've heard in months
yeah well get used to it buddy
didn't jump but my ball decided he was
just going to am a god
i'm a can you go in the hole i'm gonna
be very upset
in the hole in the whole world in
general
stupid oh there should be a big head
that says stupid stupid way
he was so stupid i'm sure we could put
that together
oh stupid
oh my god oh come on
is this a jump is this a jump my dudes
is this feels like a jump
together oh please no yes
no oh hey bud
no wait a minute you first thanks we'll
do you
uh go to the left it's mark the left
pull damn it yeah
why aren't you jumping you dumb piece of
garbage what was wrong with me oh
my god did harry you're a wizard
all over the place i'm practically
gerald
let's not jump to conclusions oh this is
a jump oh
oh my god mark you actually are a
guarantor i
know some kind of gary hey what the hell
wait what the hell uh sorry i was trying
hey wait stop me thank you
oh my god i just spat the biggest glob
of spit
all over my entire screen dude i am not
a gary
i'm much more of a friend is that good
i don't think so oh there's a there's
that's a that's a trick
what am i expecting here what am i
looking it's a wrap around two oh it
oh it is a jump oh god yeah it's a jump
across okay
okay okay okay yeah oh i carried too
hard i'll
wait okay it stops oh wow
hey mark how's it going that was good
no oh man
what happened i hit like the hot wheels
accelerator bump
oh yes hello friends yes yes
oh
that was great that was perfection
actually oh wow that's actually really
smart
my brain was almost flipped blessed
no smooth
oh hey buddy hey bud what's up man with
us being in the safe
yeah you know how it is you know how
it'd do oh i don't like the sound of
whatever happened to wade hey wade
wait i'll get you i got you buddy i got
your buddy absolutely don't help me
i don't know how much there we go okay
there you go thanks for the holding one
there
i got six how did i get six on that
six six six all right you guys
say another one oh my god oh
hello oh okay oh no
oh no oh no he says oh no oh no oh no
no no oh yeah oh
uh oh yeah oh so close
if me helping you on that wave makes you
win and me lose
if that costs me the game i'm gonna be
so mad oh my god
look at this hole before we do anything
everyone just take it away you know what
actually you're right this is uh this is
a this is a real monster this is a dude
oh right in the hole
wait a minute don't stop jumping no stop
believing
oh [ __ ] no oh why did i jump oh why did
i jump please i feel really guilty now
oh oh my god no not that one no not that
one not
oh no not that okay it's fine no you
shot your mouth
wade did you get a hole in one or
something
southern you shut your mouth out you
really have to mess this up to lose i
will remark i'll help
thank you i don't like the health but
come on
i i could have just
ahead of you i am three dimensions
beyond